there are familiar sight in Goma
Chuco dues cargo carrying scooters made
in Congo
durable wood and patient craftsmanship
are what it takes to make them Sebastian
and Pascal learned how from his father
he charges $100 for two kudu it's pretty
hard work the most difficult part is
whittling everything down so that the
parts fit together almost all the parts
come from the region Pascal and his
colleagues go at it for up to three days
until everything fits only then is the
chickadee ready to roll it not only
transports people but staggering loads
of just about anything
in downtown Goma a statue has been
erected in honor of this prized means of
transportation
we used to not have things like
motorcycles but we have the chuka do to
help us transport goods it was invented
here in coma that's why we have this
statue this to could do reflects comas
image
it symbolizes our city and that makes us
happy
I chose how they have to work so hard
just in their life here in Goma
meanwhile Sebastian Pascal has arrived
at his family home his sister is proud
of the hard-working true kudu
constructor we have enough to eat and
send the kids to school Pascal was
convinced that hard work is the only way
forward in crisis-ridden
eastern Congo and so he's on the road
again hauling new wood for the next two
kudu